so we've already spent some time
introducing ourselves to the idea of
adding or subtracting positive and
negative numbers and what I now want to
do in this video is do a bunch of
examples using the adding negative
numbers on the number line exercise on
Khan Academy so that we can think about
different ways to a model or think about
or visualize adding and subtracting
positive and negative numbers so this
question asks us which number line model
represents the expression negative 2
plus negative 7 and a number line model
seems like this really fancy thing but
they're just saying well which of these
which of these diagrams which of these
drawings are a way to think about what
negative 2 plus negative 7 is so let's
think about it someone has I'm want to
start at negative 2 and then to that I
want to add negative 7 so let's see
what's going on here so this is this
number line model I guess we could call
it it's saying it's starting this is
positive 2 right over here this to the
right of 0 and then it and then it
subtracts 7 so this is the model that
would be 4 positive 2 plus negative 7 or
2 or positive 2 minus 7 but that's not
what we have over here we have negative
2 minus 7 this one right over here let's
see this first I guess you could say
this thing this this this line this
arrow it's going 1 2 3 4 5 to the left
of 0 so starting at negative 5 and then
it goes another 1 2 3 4 to the left of
that so you could view this as negative
5 minus 4 or you could view this as
negative 5 plus negative 4 but that's
not what we have up here and then this
last one hopefully this is the answer
otherwise there'd be some mistake in the
exercise let's see we have this first
arrow that takes us two steps to the
left of 0 so 1 2 so this is negative 2
and then we take another 7 steps to the
left of that so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so you can
think of this arrow is representing
negative 2 and then we're going to do
that so we're starting from this tip of
this our
we're going to add a negative seven
which makes us move seven to the left
again to get to negative nine so that's
definitely the model that represents
that expression let's keep going all
right which number line model represents
the expression six plus negative two so
here they've taken our number lines but
they've made them they made them go up
and down they've made them vertical so
we want to one way to think buddy I want
to start at six and then I want to add
negative two so on a vertical number
line like this and it seems like we're
increasing as we go up I want to start
at six above zero so I want to start at
six above zero but then I want to add
negative two which should take me two
steps back down this one takes me two
steps even higher so this is this one
right over here is positive six plus 2
or positive six plus positive two this
one over here we're starting at positive
4 and then we're adding two so that's
not what we're talking about this one
over here this big error this tall arrow
this is going it's pointing up it gets
us to positive six the tip of the arrows
right at positive six but then we go
back down to so this would be positive
six plus negative two you could think of
this hours representing positive six and
then this arrow is representing negative
two it takes us to down so if you take
positive six plus negative two you the
positive six so then the tip of your
arrow from there you could start the
negative two and you go to back down and
you end up at four so it's definitely
that one right over there this is
surprisingly fun let's keep going which
number line model represents the
expression negative 2/5 plus 4/5 so
we're going to start at negative 2/5
which is going to be its negative it's
going to be to the left of zero so let's
see this this arrow right over here this
is negative 4/5 so that's not going to
be quite right so the second choice
what's going on here so if I start at
zero and then I'm going neat I'm going
to fist to the left of zero so that's
negative 2/5 and from that I'm going to
the right 1/5 2/5 3/5 4/5 so this looks
right this looks like negative 2/5 so
I'm starting at 0 I'm going to the left
2/5 so
it's negative two fists and then I go to
the right for fists from that tip so I'm
from negative two-fifths I'm adding four
fists so that looks right let's do one
more this is this is exciting and even
if you don't find it fully exciting
anything you do you should convince
yourself it's exciting you'll do a
better job which number line model
represents the expression five and a
half plus negative three so five this is
positive five and a half so I want to
say I want to go five and a half to the
right of zero this is this is five and a
half to the left of zero so that's
negative five and a half that's not what
I want to deal with so this one looks
interesting this one now this is
actually five and a half to the left of
zero as well so it's probably going to
be this but let's just look at it so
let's see we go five and a half to the
right of zero so this is five and a half
and then from that I go three left so
that inde and it gets me to two and a
half so it's this choice right over
there
exciting